the elves of hills
brooks standing lakes and groves
and you on the sands with printless foot
to chase the ebbing neptune
and to fly him when he comes back new
demi puppets that by moonshine do the
green sour ringlets make
where of the you not bites and you whose
pastime
is to make midnight mushrooms
that rejoice to hear the solemn curfew
by whose aid
weak masters though ye be
i have bedemmed the noontide sun
called forth the mutinous winds and twix
the green sea and the azir vault
set roaring war to the dread rattling
thunder have i
given fire and rifted jove's stout oak
with his own bolt
the strong-based promontory of i made
shaken by the spurs
plucked up the pine and cedar
graves at my command have waked their
sleepers oped
and led him forth by my
so potent art
but this rough magic i hear abdul
and when i have required some heavenly
music which even now i do
to work my end upon their senses that
this airy charm is for
i'll break my stuff
bury it certain fathoms in the earth
and deeper than did ever plummet sound
i'll drown my book
you